pierre ory bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
cette journée mondiale des réfugiés est
l'occasion de faire un bilan forum
réfugiés a sorti son rapport annuel sur
l'asile en france et en europe et ce
rapport dénonce des procédures longues
et des demandes de traitement qui
continuent de s'allonger
quelle est votre réaction face à ce
constat alors là si tu es si on est
effectivement complexe dans le monde
près de 80 millions de réfugiés
c'est un chiffre qui a été multiplié par
dix ans et la situation il est
évidemment problématique dans notre
propre pays mais il faut se rappeler que
l'europe n'est pas le premier pays
d'accueil des réfugiés mais le continent
africain il sait le continent ne
asiatiques et cela doit être dans toutes
les têtes et par ailleurs la plupart des
réfugiés proviennent de syrie
proviennent d'afghanistan provient du
soudan et ça met en exergue le
multilatéralisme se porte très mal si on
veut réduire le nombre de réfugiés dans
le monde des indispensables que la
communauté internationale retrouvent le
chemin de la négociation
on va y revenir effectivement à ces
négociations nécessaires pour répondre à
ce défi migratoire pour revenir en
france au début de son mandat le
président de la république avec un
objectif instruire les demandes d'asile
en six mois ce n'est pas le cas pourquoi
l'objectif n'est-il pas atteint selon
vous
d'abord je vous rappelle qu'il ya une
crise migratoire sans précédent et que
la france par exemple est un des pays
qui se situe en tête du palmarès de
l'accueil 135 mille personnes médaille
quant à l'objectif de 6 mois pour
traiter les demandes des mcv
c'est pas très nouveau en 2003 jacques
chirac qui était président de la
république connaît le même objectif et
aujourd'hui nous en sommes toujours un
an
voilà parce que tout simplement nous
sommes dans un état de droit afin que
les possibilités de recours avec des
structures indépendantes qui prennent
leurs décisions et compris en intégrant
la dimension du temps et donc il ya des
moments qui sont incompressibles
c'est pour ça que quand nos politiques
d'hommes l'objectif étant de six mois
vous savez ce n'est qu'un objectif qui
est toujours très difficilement atteint
difficilement atteinte en une démocratie
et dans un détachement
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
nécessaire coordination des pays dans le
monde pour faire face à ce défi
migratoire
selon vous quels moyens la france
doit-elle mettre en oeuvre pour traiter
cette problématique à la fois à
l'intérieur de ses frontières mais aussi
à l'extérieur c'est-à-dire d'un point de
vue diplomatique avec les pays notamment
ceux des réfugiés mais c'est pas
simplement les pays des réfugiés parce
que les pays des réfugiés en question ne
vous a pas échappé qu'un certain nombre
de grandes puissances étaient à l'oeuvre
le ton le chaos et qu'ils contribuent et
cao donc comme je parle du
multilatéralisme
mais je parle évidemment par exemple de
l'ensemble des nations qui sont et qui
interviennent au sein du conseil de
sécurité si tout le monde n'y met pas de
la bonne volonté
évidemment chaque année le bond de
réfugiés va augmenter il n'y a pas 36
solutions il faudrait d'abord ne pas
créer des situations de conflit ou ne
pas les entretenir si je prends la
situation de la syrie
il est évident qu'un certain nombre de
puissants sans cadavre maigre autour du
conflit qui ravage son pays depuis près
de 10 ans mais si je vous prends un
autre pays comme
lee c'est exactement la même situation
avec des acteurs qui divin quelquefois
donc la france soit crude sa part en
matière de multilatéralisme
mais ce n'est pas le seul le pays qui
est concerné ce n'est pas la seule
nation compte à l'intérieur de nos
frontières
je crois qu'il s'agit de restes donné on
se disant que c'est la cinquième
puissance du monde et qu'il y a des
choses qui sont impossibles à accepter
comme par exemple l'indignité qui
consiste à laisser des gens à la rue
voilà ce n'est pas possible
l'hébergement doit être inconditionnelle
ce qui ne signifie en aucune façon que
cela peut dire séjour inconditionnels
ces deux choses différentes
parce que les situations de rue les gens
laissés à la rue
là vous savez ça provoque des tensions
avec la population locale et ça alimente
tous les polémiques tous les to les
populistes et donc c'est quelque chose
qu'il appartient aux politiques et au
gouvernement de traiter avec raison pour
conclure en quelques mots ils sont
nombreux cet après-midi dans les rues de
paris de travailleurs sans papiers comme
on les appelle à demander à être
régularisés il faut le faire pour vous
écoutez j'ai toujours considéré que le
mot d'ordre des papiers pour tous les
sans papiers était un mot d'ordre
erronée mais le mot régularisation n'est
pas un gros mot oui il faut régulariser
personnes et en premier lieu je pense
notamment à ceux qui travaillent
véritablement qui ont un emploi
puis je pense aussi à ces femmes qui
sont allées peut-être de faibles y
monoparentales est dans une démocratie
personne n'ira jamais cherché ces femmes
un beau matin avec leurs enfants pour
les remettent dans un avion à partir de
ce moment là il faut pas les laisser
gamin qu'il faut pas les laisser vivre
dans des hôtels sociaux avec leurs
enfants qui grandissent dans une
situation de d'endroits donc il faut pas
avoir peur de les régulariser donc on
régularise oui mais sur critères
merci beaucoup pierre henry d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur général de france
terre d'asile et président de france
fraternité